Let's talk now about how we compute stereo
disparity. We have a pair of images taken
by a stereo camera. We have a left image and
a right image, and our goal is to compute
what we call a disparity image. In the disparity
image, the brightness of a pixel corresponds
to the stereo disparity at that particular
point.
A point that's bright has got a large stereo
disparity and that occurs when an object is
close to us, and a darker pixel has got a
smaller disparity and corresponds to an object
that is further away. We want to understand
how we can take that original left and right
image, process it and turn it into this disparity
image. The fundamental principle of this computational
stereo can be described quite simply.
Here are two pictures that I took of the Eiffel
Tower from slightly different viewpoints.
Let's consider a single point on the top of
the tower. I'm going to select a window of
pixels around that, and I'm going to make
a copy of that window of pixels and there
it is at the top.
Now I'm going to transfer the distance U to
the right hand image and do a little bit of
construction. I am going to say that the disparity
that I am looking for has got a maximum value
that I'm going to call D-max. Now, the stereo
process involves looking for that little template
of the top of the Eiffel Tower at every possible
position along that search line and the best
fit is clearly at this particular location,
which is a distance D away from the vertical
reference line that I drew.
D is the value of the disparity at this point.
Clearly this is quite a computationally intensive
process. I have to do a template match at
a number of different possible disparity values
from zero up to D-max. And this is just to
determine the disparity at the coordinate U, V.
I actually need to do this for every single
pixel in the input image. It is certainly
a lot of computation, but with today's computers
it can be done very, very quickly even for
very high resolution stereo image pairs.
Let's load a stereo pair into our workspace.
I'm going to load the left image from the
file ROX2-L and I'm going to load the right
image from ROX2-R. I've used the reduce option
to iread the resolution in the horizontal
and vertical direction because these are very,
very high-resolution images and the stereo
computation is a little slow under MATLAB.
The first thing I’m going to do is to display
the images as an anaglyph. Parse the left
and right images to the anaglyph function
and here we see an anaglyph representation
of this stereo scene of a pile of rocks. If
I had my red and blue glasses on, this would
look very powerfully three-dimensional.
Let’s have a look at the left and right
images in a bit more detail. I’m going to
use the toolbox function, stdisp, stereo display
and it gives a window that looks something
like this and I’m just going to make that
a little bit wider.
Now, here we see the left image and the right
image. Let me just click on a particular point
in the image. I’m going to click on this
rock in the foreground. I’m going to click
on that particular blotch there and if I go
to the other image and that’s the same blotch;
it’s just there,
I’m going to click on it and up the top
we see the disparity that is the left ward
shift in the right image and it’s 79.29
pixels. Now let’s have a look at a point
on the back. Let’s have a look at this very
distinctive valley between these two rocks
and click on that point.
I’m going to find the same point in the
other image and it’s just there and now
we see that the disparity, the left ward shift
has been reduced. It’s only 43.45 pixels.
Let’s find a point that’s somewhere in
between those things. Let’s have a look
at this white dot here and we find it in the
right image. It’s just there. In this case,
the disparity is 52 pixels.
So we can see very clearly the relationship
between depth and disparity. Points in the
foreground have got a large disparity. Points in the background have got a much smaller disparity.
Now let’s compute disparity for every single
pixel in this pair of images. I’m going
to put the disparity into the workspace variable
D. I’m going to use the toolbox function
istereo and the parse in the left image and
the right image.
The range of disparity is to search over and
for this particular pair, I've worked out
that the smallest disparity is 40 pixels and
the largest disparity is 90 pixels and I’m
parsing the half width of the matching window.
The matching window will be three times two
plus one. That’s a seven by seven window.
Computation takes a moment or two and now
I can display the disparity image and here
we see it. If I can click on some pixels here
we see in the foreground this rock here has
got disparities starting off around 83 falling
away as the cross-binding points in the world
get further away from the camera, falls off
to 70 something. These rocks up the back here
have got a much smaller disparity, the order
of 50. This rock’s something like 40 and
these really dark ones up the back have a
disparity of 45 or 46.
We can see that this image is far from perfect.
There are some points that just don’t look
right. There are some very anomalous bright
points around the edges of the rocks and that’s
because those parts of the rock are visible
from one camera view but not visible from
the other camera view and that means that
the stereo matching can’t be completed properly.
You also note that there’s a black region
down the side of the image and that’s where
the fields of view of a camera don’t fully
overlap. This is a very simplistic stereovision
algorithm. There are much more sophisticated techniques available but it demonstrates the principle.
The toolbox function that draws 3D coordinate
frames has an anaglyph mode. If we call the
trplot function which we've seen before, it
will parse in a rotation of 90 degrees around
the X axis so that’s the coordinate frame
that we want to display. We parse the 3D plot
option and if I view this through my anaglyph
glasses, I get a very realistic 3D impression.
I actually see that Z axis coming out of the
screen somewhat.